you look sensational right now with your
final game of Thrones premiere how are
you feeling I feel like really nice no I
feel great like this is so exciting this
is the best way to end something like
this being with all of your best friends
we're like really expensive dresses and
all just play and dress up and up in a
great home so I'm happy if you like the
next time you're gonna get to do this is
it Sophie's wedding so that's amazing
yeah the next time I don't know I've got
like many many other ovens no just
maybes wedding yeah
had you already started thinking about
your dress for that wedding because this
one's amazing I can't even be thinking
about bad choice when I'm wearing
something like this Bemis Lawrence has
so many fans out there are so many celeb
fans who's come up to you and fanboy
door fangirled the most oh I heard the
other day that Kobe Bryant wants me to
kill him like put him on it my list and
I was like hon you're on my lids don't
worry about it on-screen brother Kit
Harington is hosting SNL this weekend
how do you think he's gonna do oh my god
kids like not funny so it's gonna be
hilarious we want to go and boo him ya
know I'm sure he's gonna be great
he's gonna be wonderful he'll be good
yeah so we have a question that was left
for you by one of your cast member so
Hilo said who on Game of Thrones has the
best costumes
I think Circe's costumes of the best
I've always loved her she's got to she
wore this red dress I think in season
one that was like a little boat neck and
it was incredible
yeah Circe 100% has the best outfits you
leave me a question
that'll go to the next person who
probably go to Sophie so you leave me a
question for Sophie I'm which cast
member which cast member does is the
most annoying yeah glad to do it
lastly give me one word to describe
Arya's journey this season
Cohen she's gone she's torn in two
are you torn about your next role where
you gonna do next oh yeah no I'm not
gonna do a little ingenuity in a few
weeks which will be good fun site set in
the 90s and it's like a horror film yeah
so Abbi good fun gonna wash my hair out
and make it yellow just coast like the
90s it's all about that bleach you look
amazing go have fun thank you
[Music]